yeah it's it's it's it's one of the you
know it's funny I was in and uh and it's
crazy and I didn't make I didn't say
anything but I was about to like make
like a bit about it so so in in the room
so literally I was in you know sway
right
sway is like I hosted a show in 2014 on
MTV with sway I was because nobody
watched it but it was called off the bat
but anyway sway taught me so much
knowledge about like hosting a show and
being on camera and just being in this
world sway is like I love sway I think
he might be the father of my youngest
kid and and I love it please you know
she misses you
um so so sway sway is the best but I
remember I was in Sway in the Morning
yeah you know as a guest on on his
serious show with the whole Jesse
Smollett oh thing broke right yeah and I
was in there white guy you know you know
all Black cast
in there rather be everybody and they're
and they're there and they're just
letting Tracy's reading it and she's
like you know and it's horrible and it's
like the [ __ ] energy in there it's
like oh [ __ ] and then they say it
they're like you know uh um jussie
Smollett was was you know attacked
beaten by two white uh you know that
they were saying at the time two white
men
um and they were like you know you know
they they threw acid at him and a noose
and they said you you must be you're
that you're that guy from Empire you
know what uh whatever you're like those
rednecks watch Empire you're that guy
from Empire and so at that point I was
about to say I don't think that's real
because no white people watch Empire and
uh and then and I didn't say it and if I
would have said it then it would I would
have been like thrown out and
scrutinizing canceled but literally I
would have been right but you would have
been right because when I heard that
story I was like everything everything
checks out but not that yeah because my
comic mine was like anybody with a mega
hats not watching Empire yeah I was like
this is a hoax but you know it was funny
like and sometimes I'm like yo I should
have just did The Joke Man I'm a comic
but then I was like yo I love story and
that might have cost you your friendship
for a few months you did it yeah exactly
what it caused my friendship for about
six months and I'm like come on come on
you know I was right yeah yeah but but
but it was one of those things where I
remember that moment being like yo
um uh but but yeah man I think too with
comedy you know the beautiful thing
about being a comic is my shows man I
got it the thing one of the things I'm
most proud of it's very culturally
diverse man it's like a community
college when you come to my show dude
everybody's out there all different
religions races it's it's dope so um
because I think you know comedy is one
of those things where it's like we just
go up there confident with the jokes
Comedy is not supposed like when people
get mad at Comics they're such [ __ ]
nerds because it's like the comic is the
member of society it's supposed to say
the thing they're supposed to say things
nobody else could say because it's an
outlet that's why we do it in dark dingy
basements I'm not telling you go tell
your friends at the water cooler [ __ ]
dummy yeah but you know like so so so I
think though for the most part too at
least with Comics you know if it's just
words actions are you know uh you know
you do some criminal [ __ ] that's the
eyes of the law but comics with words I
think it's happening less and less with
the quote unquote cancel stuff because
it's like yo we're coming in my opinion
you cannot be funny and hateful like you
it's you're one of the other like you
know Hitler wasn't funny because all
hate so it's like you if you're funny
and and the joke comes off wrong that's
why Connie's subjective it may not be
for you that's fine right it's intent
based it's like what was your intent
with this yeah it wasn't to like be
hateful or to be yeah or to hurt
feelings it was to make light of
something everyone's thinking about
anyway yeah because you gotta understand
too man like any big Uprising you know I
love hearing some big history fan you
cannot you know like silence comics and
artists you can't do that because I'm
telling you when it comes down to it
like you know in the Holocaust you know
they kill the artist in comic they
killed them first because they don't
want you they don't these these regime
doesn't want people talking and open you
know dialogue like we have what we have
in this country right now is such a
beautiful thing you can you can we can
have differences of opinions you know we
all that stuff you know like like this
discourse that's like fine but this
these groups of people that wanna you
know like you know they'll say silence
is violence unless I speak up and say
what you don't want me to say then you
try to silence me so if the premise of
it doesn't make any sense to me it never
did right so I'm like so I'm like as a
comic I'm like yo we gotta all just keep
talking about whatever it is you want to
talk about uh because you need us you
know just like we need musicians and and
all that and the people try to silence
like I don't know why at times
politicians you know will get you know
Comics will get treated like politicians
and politicians will get treated like
Comics like as a comic that's true you
know it's I mean think about the Trump
[ __ ] he got the pass like he was a
comedian for so much of the [ __ ] he said
yeah and then there'll be comedians
around that same time the Kevin Hart
thing happened yeah where it's like wait
which one is which yeah like like it's
almost like this this little like defect
in society where it's like what you're
attacking like the wrong people man like
I'm a comic I'm not I'm not I don't have
anything to do with Congress like you
know but but the people who had
something to do with Congress like you
said the the free pass so it's just been
an interesting thing but that's why but
I think you know again turning to an
audience and a fan base that just likes
what I do it's almost like well you know
I think this idea of being generically
famous isn't realistic anymore like
you're not good with too much of a niche
Society now I think the same with music
and and comedy and movies it's like you
know it's it's only for a certain group
of people but go for that I mean you
know now these movies that when you know
Oscars most of us have never seen them
or we don't know you know you you you
don't know who yeah they'll announce the
best pictures of the year and I'm like
I've never because it's because it's not
for us it's for that that Niche right
right so so so it's an interesting um
interesting thing